Christopher has this report it says in
recent years the Walt Disney Company has
become embroiled in America's culture
War as I have reported the company has
pushed critical race Theory and its
employee training programs and radical
gender ideologies children's programming
last week Disney's board of directors
fired CEO Bob chapek who lost a high
profile fight with Governor Ron DeSantis
regarding legislation restricting
radical gender theory in schools and
brought back former CEO Bob Iger to
write the ship
rufo reports I have obtained exclusive
video of iger's first town hall meeting
with Disney employees in which he
Retreats from the company's most
controversial political positions and
moves toward neutrality in the culture
War
so I want to go through some of these
videos
um as he's talking to his employees
about his vision for Disney going
forward
um and we'll start with this here's Bob
Iger answer a question about whether
Disney will uh stay out of what's Disney
going to do about politics are they
going to stay involved in politics
they're going to get out of politics
here's what he says
this is a virtual question many cast
members had wished that Disney stayed
out of politics Will Disney stay out of
making political statements
you know I think uh there's a Mis
perception here about what politics is
and I think that some of the subjects
that have proven to be controversial as
it relates to Disney have been branded
political and I don't necessarily
believe they are I don't think when you
were telling stories and attempting to
be a good citizen of the world that
that's political
just not how I view it do I like the
company being embroiled in controversy
of course not it can be distracting and
it can have a negative impact on the
company and to the extent that I can
work to kind of quiet things down I'm
going to do that but I think it's it's
important to put in perspective what
some of these subjects are and not just
simply brand them political
okay so that's a little bit uh yes on
one hand he's saying we're retreating
from politics but that he does also
offer this qualification that well I
don't consider some of this stuff to be
politics uh so that's a classic that's a
a classic move on the left is to say
well this is this this isn't political
or ideological at all
right to uh to have gay romance
storylines and and films for kids
nothing ideological or political about
that
so you can't tell based on that is this
just his way of actually doubling down
and saying we're to continue in this
direction I think it becomes more clear
when he's asked specifically about the
battle with uh with Ron DeSantis in
Florida and how he feels about that now
uh you know upon reflection here's what
he says
Bob have you ever any thoughts on how to
tackle the Reedy Creek situation in
Florida no
um I I
um I have to get up to speed on that
completely obviously I followed the news
that development occurred after I left
the company I was sorry to see us
um
dragged into that battle
um and I have no idea exactly what its
ramifications are in terms of the
business itself what I can say is the
state of Florida has been important to
us for a long time and we have been very
important to the State of Florida that
is something I'm extremely mindful of
and will articulate if I get the chance
but I don't have the details at all yet
about what the ramifications are of the
decision that was made by the state of
Florida and whether we intend to do
anything about it
okay and finally one of the clip to play
this is uh
more specifically asked about the don't
say gay Bill and remember this is what
this all traces back to as Disney came
out against the don't say gay Bill and
had this whole battle with DeSantis over
it uh the the
what they label the don't say gay Bill a
bill that we must remember that that
build never actually existed that was
invented by the left it's just to
clarify uh it was actually the
anti-groomer bill that they had a
problem with but here's what he says
about that
all right another virtual question what
is your stance on the don't say gay
situation
well first of all uh
our lgbtq employees are very important
to us and we care deeply about them that
is a given
secondly this company has been telling
stories for 100 years and those stories
have had a meaningful positive impact on
the world and one of the reasons they've
had a meaningful positive impact is
because one of the core values of our
storytelling is inclusion and acceptance
and tolerance and we can't lose that we
just can't lose that and think about I
think about Black Panther and the impact
that had on the world or a film like
Coco I mean I could go on and on and how
we actually change the world for the
good must continue we also when you tell
stories it's a delicate balance you're
talking to an audience but it's also
important to listen to an audience it's
important to have respect for the people
that you're serving that you're trying
to reach and not have disdain for it
that said
we're not going to make everybody happy
all the time and we're not going to try
to and we're certainly not going to
lessen our core values in order to make
everybody happy all the time
um so it's it's complicated and there's
a balance but and I I at one point I
said we do what we believe is right and
then someone criticized them you're
saying well who are you to say that
that's right well when you're in a job
like mine or you are responsible for the
storytelling that many of you are
responsible okay
so you want to you're talking to an
audience but you want to listen to them
and not have disdain for them that's uh
that's uh quite an interesting
Revelation don't have open contempt for
for your audience is what is what
they're realizing over at Disney or at
least is what they're saying publicly
you know gee I don't know maybe we
shouldn't be maybe we shouldn't openly
hate and we can still hate them but just
don't not let's not be so open about it
now
saw a few things about this obviously it
would be quite naive to believe that um
that this is a sign that Disney is
anti-woke now and that everything he
said about you know politics don't want
to be too involved in that they're
they're gonna withdraw completely and uh
it's gonna go back to you know they're
gonna start making
content like they made in the 1950s
right
um that's that's not going to happen I
mean Disney is run by the people it's
run by it is a it is a woke leftist
Corporation and that's probably not ever
going to change if ever did change it's
not going to happen overnight like
that's uh that's you know that's decades
long change if it ever happens at all
um
just like it took decades for Disney to
be overrun by these types of people
so it would be it would be incredibly
naive to think that that this is that
they're just
you know next thing you know Disney's
like going to be modeling itself after
the daily wire that's that's not going
to happen
however
this is also a victory it's a victory
for Ron DeSantis that's for sure
he went up against Disney and this is
Disney backing down they're they're
backing away from it
which by the way if you're one of these
people that's out there claiming now
that somehow Ron DeSantis is an
establishment Republican
is completely absurd notion well this
this should put that notion to rest
okay establishment Republicans and there
are a lot of reasons why Rhonda Sanders
is not an establishment Republican okay
um
but established Republicans
they're not going to go to war with
major corporations establishment
Republican who's a governor is not going
to go up against he's not going to pick
a fight with them with with the most
powerful corporate interest in his state
and if ever they establish a republican
pretends to be doing that he's going to
be the one who backs down quickly
that's that's one of the defining
features of the establishment
is that at the end of the day they are
they're going to Bow before Corporate
America and do as they're told
so this is not what the establishment
does
not just a victory for Rhonda say this
though it's also a victory this is a you
know for conservatives this is a
cultural victory
because even though Disney is not now
going to become conservative
they are actually responding to public
pressure that's what they're doing
um and now they're going to look for
more subtle ways to inject this stuff
into their programming which you could
argue is even more dangerous if they're
more subtle about it because you have to
look out for it more and that's true so
we kind of enter a new phase here
but even so they are responding to
pressure they are backing away they are
crumbling a little bit under pressure
and uh that's important
and it's important for us to see that we
can do that like we have that power
um
we can put pressure even on these major
corporations and we can force them to
respond to it
and that'll do it for this portion of
the shows and move over to the members
blog hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]